we begin in georgia where three men face
a possible sentence of life in prison
without parole
for killing ahmad arbury yesterday a
jury found travis mcmichael his father
gregory mcmichael and their neighbor
william roddy bryant guilty of murder in
last year's shooting of the 25 year old
as he jogged through a neighborhood in
brunswick georgia civil rights leaders
from across the country were on hand for
the verdict along with arbory's family
his relatives had fought for months to
get justice after a prosecutor initially
declined to charge the defendants omar
villafranca is outside the courthouse
omar you've been following this case
from the very beginning what's the
reaction there
well good morning the jury was made up
of one black person the rest were white
and they deliberated for more than 11
hours and ultimately decided that the
three white men charged with murder
were guilty
count one malice murder
we the jury find the defendant travis
mcmichael guilty
ahmad arbury's father couldn't hold back
as judge timothy walmsley read
wednesday's verdict i'm going to ask
that whoever
just made it out first be removed from
the court please in total travis and
gregory mcmichael and william roddy
bryan were found guilty on 23 counts
travis mcmichael was found guilty on all
of his charges as he left court
red-faced he mouthed love you to his
mother the defendants were found guilty
of murdering arbory in february 2020
while arbory was out for a jog in a
southern georgia neighborhood the
defense argued the defendants thought
arbory was a burglar and attempted to
make a citizen's arrest travis mcmichael
fired his shotgun three times the 25
year old arbory was unarmed cell phone
video of the killing taken by brian
revealed the incident igniting
nationwide protests prosecutor linda
donakosky says she had confidence in the
jury you finished with your final
rebuttal of the closing arguments what
are you thinking now that the jury has
the case and they're going back to
deliberate i thought
i'm done they've got it they're smart
they paid really close attention they
took a lot of notes they're gonna get
this they're gonna do the right thing
this is a very difficult day for travis
mcmichael and greg mcmichael
these are two men who honestly believe
that what they were doing
was the right thing to do attorney jason
sheffield represents travis mcmichael
that is a very disappointing and sad
verdict but we also recognize that this
is a day of celebration for the arbory
family we understand that they feel they
have gotten justice today
we respect that we honor that ahmad
arbury's mother wanda cooper jones set
in court throughout the trial
on wednesday she walked out of the
building to cheers
i never thought this day would come but
god is good he will now rest in hey
man defense attorneys say they plan to
appeal no sentencing date has been set
but the minimum penalty for murder is
life in prison if a judge allows the
possibility of parole eligibility would
only come after serving 30 years
all right omar thank you